each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
so I'm very excited to welcome in
Mozilla coozer
assistant professor at Stanford
University and he runs the cruiser nap
and he will talk about interactive
biotechnology and also about different
platforms about sorry
biotic games and also how to create like
low-cost
low-cost do-it-yourself kits with
smartphones thank you very much so
welcome thank you for having me
so as the picture here indicates one of
the major themes in my lab that we're
interested in is we see how can we make
the microscopic world that we usually
can see through a microscope actually
interactive right we can look through a
microscope but we can't touch we can't
actuate and this is the kind of thing we
want to enable in very different ways
and for many different reasons as I will
show you my talk so let's start with
these two pictures which I guess are
kind of familiar to you but just asking
the audience what's the difference
between those say something
one is tactile okay okay what else so
they're different users exactly so
essentially they are like 50 years
difference about between these two in
both cases we see computers and we see
humans interacting with those and as you
appreciate these early computers who are
primarily about number crunching they
weren't very effective by today's
standards they were hard to operate well
those days these devices basically
provide a human interactive experience
at this kind of child play and that is
very very powerful
right and so 50 years of technological
development made lots of things possible
and if you now look into biotechnology
we can actually see what's going on
there right now see similarities to what
has been in electronics unlike 50 years
ago and kind of try to project where
should we go with that in in the biotech
space and just to
okay so now the movies don't run I don't
know why what do you see here is as a
microfluidic chips um can we get the
movies I tested it before it didn't run
then it ran no it doesn't run again okay
let me let me try to walk you through um
so what do you see here is basically
microcytic chip it's like a network of
little channels it has valves in there
so you can move fluid and little
packages around it's used for
Diagnostics for examples if you have a
droplet of blood and you want to do
diagnostics of understanding which kind
of disease markers or other things you
have you can imagine how these kind of
particles are moved around on this chip
in a kind of process and there are many
relationship chips to to these early
computers they can be run in a lab by
expert people but they are not readily
available for for day-to-day use right
and so this technology gets better
there's something similar like Moore's
laws to it so can we
basically get to a more human
interactive experience with those ones
as well and so the first thing I want to
tell you about is what we started with
is the idea of making games and these
types of platforms right even better the
first computers one of the first thing
people did was making games to kind of
show how you can interact with those
machines so what are biotic games we're
interested in in machines that have two
basic features one is it should really
allow a human to interact with these
biological processes at a small scale
and you should really have something to
do with modern biotechnology right so
what we don't mean as a pure emulation
and we also don't mean something more
macroscopic like horse polo which we
could call ancient biotechnology right
what do you see here as a single-celled
organism called paramecia it's
relatively large 250 microns this is a
very simple - the micro feeding shift
where you see these little speckles here
these other cells and it is you four
electrodes and if you apply an electric
field you can make those cells kind of
swarm along the field lines to do
behavior called galvano taxes and so
here's the
kind of a joystick or kind of a gamepad
where you actuate those those electric
fields and then you can basically in
real time on a computer screen see how
these cells move now if you put some
virtual objects on top of it and
integrate some tracking mechanism you
can play games with that right like in
the thing that you just saw it was about
getting points by swimming through these
dots in this case you try to get kind of
a virtual soccer ball into a goal right
and so you could kind of envision and
saying this is basically an interactive
biology experiments or you could say
this is a game right and so in this sort
of game engine so to speak you can now
create many different games by just
implementing different types of skins on
top of it right making different rules
new things yes so the first you mean
what is the in-game goal of what what is
the ring so so the initial research goal
was like I mean could we make games on
this type of platform and even asking
like what would these games even be look
like right and before video games came
around no one knew what a video game was
right and we have seen this tremendous
evolution based on technology that let
there and so it's it's a it's so yes so
there's lots of so the initial thing is
let's make games let's make an
interactive experience and show that it
can be done and then there's the
secondary question what is this good for
right and I come to things like informal
and formal biology education right so
that that may be one one application
there so here so you can kind of to set
up so it's very simple right at his open
ship a hacked webcam and then you
basically project this on the screen so
this was kind of a very early a first
thing that we built and kind of late a
paradigm off of what a game could be
like on that sort of platform and since
then we've basically gone quite a
further down the road and so the next
system I want to tell you uses a
different organism called Euglena it's
about 50 micrometer in size a little bit
bit smaller it's green it's
photosynthetic and it has this nice
little red eye spot which is actually
uses two senses 3d environment and has
these flagella to kind of
Pellatt self forward through the fluid
and so in this particular project we
wanted to set up a system wake and play
through a smartphone and where we also
have a much more robust and reliable on
kind of game experience than what you
saw in the previous one so the education
motivations behind those is if you look
at other kind of areas especially in
mechatronics with the robotics and also
computers with the video game national
video game challenges I'm always kind of
envious because you see we have these
beautiful toys that are kind of engaged
kids and students to learn about these
technologies built something have fun
and and intrinsically alone we don't
really have that to that extent yet in
in in biology right and so here again
these these cells that I just spoke
about is you gain ourselves right I'm
swimming so the fluid a little bit about
their biophysics so to speak so they
have this ice but they have this long
l'chayim
and essentially they can roll or they do
roll kind of in a 3d helical motion so
the fluid yeah by with the ice but kind
of samples 3d space and then there's a
feedback loop between the flagellum and
this and this ice pot and this allows
them to basically for example go to the
light if the light is very dim because
they need light for photosynthesis walk
away from the light if the light is very
strong because the don't wanna get
sunburn right and primarily here we use
the negative phototaxis and so here's on
this setup on this phone setup the kind
of games that we did we implemented it's
very similar setup as before but instead
of electrodes we have LEDs now and then
light is much easier to control in many
aspects right and so what do you see if
your differences to the games I show you
before it's in color right you made some
advancement there which you may not
appreciate is now these cells live for a
couple of days in this chamber so you
almost get a pluck and play experience
right if you turn this thing on you can
play and then you can turn it off again
and we've also already indicated a
number of things that are kind of
directly educational so your skills you
see a scale bar here you see the
velocity down here of any sort of cell
that basically is swimming
sooo this object right now this cell is
tracked and then you see kind of the
real-time velocity
you also see whatever cell is tracked
you kind of see the cell and lodge and
so the ideas while you play with these
things there are many subtle ways how
you can convey the learn order to player
and some things that is relevant about
biology right which would not get if you
would play a purely electronic version
of that so just to summarize again so
this is kind of this phone you can
actually completely build it yourself
for the CD printer and some simple
electronics and you can interact
essentially in two different ways there
with these cells one is you kind of tap
on this screen with your finger and
select a cell of interest and the other
user joystick to apply a light stimulus
and and make the cells move and as I
will show you in the next few slides
there kind of three modalities of
learning or education that we have in
here one is you can build a system
yourself you can do inquiry by really
doing experiments or you can just play
right so we tested this with a number of
children and science fairs and here see
kind of different age groups what I kind
of get out of it when when they draw um
and you see for example here this 8 year
old kind of drawing little X on it so
which these cells don't have but clearly
reflecting that the child realizes this
is something living right we also had
some test questions about like how big
are these cells are fasted is swimming
which you could see from the game as I
showed you before where we generally
find is that above around 11 years the
kids fully get that below kids enjoy it
but may not fully understand what's
going on this actually also nicely
aligns with kind of typical biology
curricula in middle school when kind of
most of biology is taught here's
basically the whole set up to build
something like this so you do some
sweetie printing you have some very
simple microfluidics which you can make
with some double-sided tape and some
plastic very simple electronic circuit
and so ideas like built this learn these
concepts in an integrated way right and
here's another one to do more serious
experiments so for example instead of
building the whole microscope you can
also put this interrogation chamber on
the phone directly on a regular school
microscope which makes the whole thing
cheaper and then we've made some ABS
very and for
example track individual cells on the
light stimulus or kind of measure a
number of velocity traces and you can
ask hypotheses to the cells for example
swimming faster than the light is on
versus non right you can really do the
whole scientific method on a system like
that and we also were kind of thinking
how could we integrate a programming in
there so programming in Android which we
did is a little bit hot and so we've
recited to this scratch children
programming language where we set up a
simple model which is actually all shown
here this the whole equation that
describes the motion the animation of
these cells and then you can basically
program games on top of that or more
serious experiments right and so we're
now in the process I'm kind of -
engaging with teachers more directly and
seeing how this could kind of flow into
in the school curricula or after school
and hopefully in the long run has a
similar impact like for example as Lego
Mindstorms right so now let me go to the
second project uses again these same
Cuttino yeah okay
don't teachers ask you about more
serious research questions you could be
doing with these cells like what are
they good for what do they do yeah so um
so we actually so I think the question
of cells dying may be adults very more
than 10 children so we had a number of
teachers actually coming to our lab and
showed them and interviewed them what
they've found valuable and what not so
some of the things the teachers really
found very valuable is already just
having a screen where multiple people
could look at it or just pointing on a
cell and then tracing it some teachers
were less excited about the game aspect
some teachers feel games are very good
for learning other feel it's not not
there yet right so it really knows is
the question how to really bring this to
the classroom right on how to make it
meaningful for the teacher so that's
really the next step
or something useful as opposed to speed
could you teach them anything about what
they sold actually do so I mean you can
teach them for example they respond to
light I mean already the concept that
cells have an organelle that sees light
so to speak right and it can respond to
it and then
always having close feedback loop to the
always go bit alight I mean that's
that's an important concept right
another thing
okay I just okay good so so in a in the
second project we based use the same
cells but write a different set of
stimuli it's again light but it's light
from above and so we have much more
program ability as you will see now so
this is a touchscreen what you see here
are the cells swimming and whenever you
draw under touch screen is directly
projected onto these cells right and so
you draw a circle in blue light and so
the cells avoid this blue light and you
can essentially trap a cell here you
can't wrap another cell there right um
so just to loop this so watch out for
this cell here right it's kind of
swimming and then it hits the light and
turns around right and so you it's
actually also a much more natural
stimulus than what I showed you before
because here you really see the stimulus
while the other one with the joystick
some light from the side this is maybe
not always that directly recognizable
right so what's the setup behind that um
it's essentially a normal projector with
a slightly different object sorry
project up takes to to make it small and
then you have a standard microscope with
a camera to kind of feed it back into
the touchscreen and then also have an
IPS right a regular so you can really
also see not only the cells but also
what you what you project and here what
this movie is showing is that you can do
this on a slightly different length
scale right by zooming out and again you
can see how the cells basically go away
from this blue light and start
assembling and these other and this
outer areas so this is what the Machine
looks like this is the view through the
eyepiece very see the cells here and you
also see kind of what you draw on this
this becomes important later so you'll
see
so now you can do a number of things
with it for example simple science
activities you can ask which Carlos do
these cells respond to so user can
choose different colors right like which
on red or green and noticing that the
cells whenever the encounters that sort
of light they don't respond but if
there's the blue light they do respond
right very simple example of a
scientific inquiry activity
and you can also make games on it here
for example there's this Apple and you
somehow need to steal the motion of the
cells such that they get to the Apple
right kind of try to make them bounce in
certain directions so we had this system
then tested and multiple times in a
sample say a tech museum the setup is
essentially like this big touchscreen
here and then next to it the setup which
made say me open so people could look
inside and also the eyepiece right and
so we had people coming and busy just we
watching from the distance but what
people would do and I want to walk you
through a few examples so what usually
happens is people come to the to the
touch screen start drawing it's a very
natural thing and after while they
realize there is something swimming in
the back and that whatever swimming they
are moving is actually responding to the
things that you have you draw here see
an example of where a person within 2
minutes so this whole thing is a image
sequence of 2 minutes where a person
kind of initially trapped one cell and
then made a little maze and try to get
the cell out of the maze right and so
you can we can argue that did we enable
the museum visitors to make microfluidic
circuit within 2 minutes without having
ever done this before
and doing kind of a self self-guided
experiment and we're also very
interesting kind of just having this IPS
and the touch screen if there were
multiple people usually only one person
can operate one thing so one person
started looking through the eyepiece by
the other one was drawing and then of
course they were recognizing that one
person is drawing you see in the IPS and
then people started talking to each
other and make kind of guessing games
like you draw I guess what you do and so
forth and which kind of really led to
prolonged engagement on the setup and
people spending three minutes and more
on there which is really what you kind
of want in a museum right in which again
is something which we really used to
come from physics like hands and physics
and things and interactive museums but
not that much in biology I mean apart
from petting zoos for example and just
to show you another example here this is
in cooperation with the Exploratorium
where we again use the exact same system
but now we use a Kinect as an input
device
where they can
basically users I mean detects your body
right and then projects that one into
the into the microscope what this leads
to is that first of all you kind of
project the cells in your kind of own
big space right you kind of as a person
meet the cells they are but at the same
time if you looks at the eyepiece you
see a little person dancing right in
inside the microscope and that's
actually something that especially
children very much respond to right and
so you see kind of right like with this
frame how you can also kind of trap
cells and move cells around and so I
think this this really gets gets at a
level where we could really have a
two-way experience between a human and a
microscopic organism suppose in our
scale and then they are scale and we're
kind of now developing exploring like
what are the best way to implement these
kind of activities and what does it
really mean kind of philosophically for
us and the final thing I want to tell
you in that sort of Wayne what you've
seen so far was always kind of seeing
ourselves but if you take like a million
of these of these you glean ourselves
and put them essentially in a closed
petri dish which is about this size and
then put light from below you get a
so-called bio convection patterns where
are the cells whenever there's light
I'll start swimming up and then the
cells accumulate at the top of the
surface but then the fluid gets denser
and then this dense fluid actually sinks
down and drags the cells along with it
and then I swim up again and you kind of
get very dynamic dynamic patterns and
what you can do is for example if you
have an initialization movie shows here
homogeneous distribution you show a
pattern on it you see something like
initially like a photograph almost and
then it develops further and more and
more complex pattern sign and so this is
kind of a nice complementary system to
the previous one because here you kind
of almost don't see the cells but you
really get a collector phenomena that
involves million of cells fine but again
it's it's a phototactic behavior right
okay and this one is actually then also
very easy to build because it is just
essentially this pea tradition again
these cells kind of live in there for a
couple of weeks so
okay so this was kind of our museums
museum interactive explorations and now
I want to tell you something about how
we can make biology experiments
available over the web and one of the
main motivations of that is there are
many students across the world right the
need to do would like to do biology
experiments and depending on how good
your school is situated or how dangerous
maybe even the organism is there are
lots of experiments you can't do and the
question is could we facilitate students
to work from any sort of electronic
device over the web to do to do biology
experiments and we can and we use again
this paradigm that I showed you before
with these four LEDs and basically
looking at the phototactic behavior of
these new cleaner cells so this is
essentially the website it has one big
live view of the camera which is seeing
your cells move you have this joystick
here this joystick you control the
direction of the light and you have an
external view camera view onto the
microscope so here if you watch closely
you see the different LEDs turn on and
off which is kind of important to give
give a remote user a sense of what
they're actually I'm doing right if you
follow closely now for example the
joystick points down here so this LED is
on and then you see how the cells move
downwards if you look for while you also
realize not all cells are the same some
respond more some less the difference in
size is right and so generally image
state of video data is very rich and so
beyond this simple experiment like cells
respond to light as much more to
discover and to be analyzed and in these
types of movies right so this is a is a
simple paradigm a kind of a cloud lab
and online lab but it's very good for us
because again these organisms are very
stable and we can long-term culture them
and really provide a platform that for
the end users is almost as robust as as
an etic standard electronic one right
and so in order to assess the utility
for the education so I have a strong
collaboration with Paulo Blake Steen is
a professor in education at Stanford and
so we went to San Francisco middle
school
hot end up with one teacher who teaches
multiple classes and so but in different
days the number of students basically
using our system and then not only doing
experiments but also trying to analyze
the data and then doing some modeling
experience or some modeling activity
around that so that's essentially what
the class looks like it's pretty tough
to fit in a 50-minute a class something
where do experiment analyze it and model
it and then do pre and post-test which
we also needed to do because you want to
do research here right but essentially
that's that's the layout so first two
about the experiments for the student so
there are different ways of how students
can actually do experiments in a
classroom either every student does an
experiment on their own or you kind of
do a front classroom experiment with one
student this is basically doing it on
the wall and all the students are kind
of participating what happens is that
schools have firewalls bandwidth
limitations all sorts of other things
which eventually led us to kind of
gravitate more towards the model where
this one one set up in the front of the
class but it would kind of envision that
in the long run when schools are kind of
better suited for for these kind of
things that really every student at the
same time can confront their experiments
in parallel right so then the students
after this experiment they would look at
their data basically like scrolling
through the movie and kind of analyzing
how many cells did respond to light to
the really line we also made some kind
of post image processing we're ready
from a single image you can recognize in
which directions cells are swimming and
so again the main questions that
centered around this was like t-cells
are light responsive and move away from
light and then we implemented a modeling
environment and so modeling is something
that I think is still lagging and in
middle school compared to other science
activities in my mind and how does one
even bring or enable a student to model
these kind of complex cells and what we
resided to is building an emulation
where we basically see this little box
here implemented a full 3d physics of
this cell and
student was tasked to kind of find a
parameter set of three parameters where
this cell would actually match the
swimming trace here and in purple and
this purple trace is due to a single
cell that has been tracked and the three
parameters that the student had to align
was the swimming speed how fast it rolls
around his own axis and remember it has
only one I spot right so the rolling
velocity really has an effect and also
how strongly it responds to light and
then students were basically kind of
fiddling back and forth with these
parameters and in trying to get a get a
good fit right in the future we can
think of many more sophisticated ways of
how you really teach and engage children
in in modeling but a post-test revealed
is that importantly the children learned
the content and the other thing is that
the students liked and the activity they
felt agency and felt that the
performance was successful and we also
got very good feedback from the teacher
as well was that like this was one of
the better classrooms so children were
much more alert if you kind of now think
of what are the pros and cons of normal
hands-on biology experiments or
certainly the logistics so much easier
right like the teacher doesn't have to
bring in all the microscopes and hassle
and wrestle with the with the organisms
of course on the other hand suddenly you
lose a certain tactility that you have
if you let the child kind of turn knobs
and a microscope and I think ultimately
you need to kind of do both in attend
and write certain things it's really
done well online and you can really have
the student focus and experimental
design and doesn't have to worry about
hands-on skill but in other cases you
really want to have that one as well
right so okay so what's the what's the
long-term vision of that how would that
scale in the future so what you see here
is basically a multiple of these
microscope setup so image is not very
good but essentially it's a camera here
the objective here and then this little
little chamber you may also see the
tubes where we have basically the
organisms in larger culture chambers and
we are from time to time we basically
flush fresh organisms into these
chambers and thereby having systems that
can run semi-autonomous autonomously
over over multiple we
right and so let me build out a cloud
system where we have multiple of these
machines and then have corresponding
user management where I mean how do you
queue people how do you give preferences
for example for teacher / student things
like those also if one of the machines
is broken for whatever reason right how
do you route people to a better machine
so with any sort of cloud system you
need to somehow main maintain it and
kind of monitor what's going on we have
that but there's a special aspect here
to the biology that you don't see in any
normal electronic or computation cloud
lab and that's the organisms themself
right that may for some reason not
respond as well be dead whatever and so
if you for example see this mitad
machines are not that many cells and so
we basically implemented the framework
where the each of these machines every
couple of hours runs a similar
experiment and then with object tracking
kind of recognizes how many cells are
they are they responding and what not
and if the machine is kind of not
properly working people would not be
routed at this one and we would kind of
get in a lower to kind of kind of fix it
right so kind of really getting to this
point where the end users are kind of
can log on and gets routed to something
that gives gives a good good experience
if you think about cost and scale up um
so the whole technology behind it as you
saw in the talk before is a very simple
microscope very simple chip you can run
the whole machine with a webcam and
Raspberry Pi and if you put all this
together a setup costs maybe 150 dollars
and if you don't think you have many of
those and has someone to maintain it you
can also think of this that an average
cost maybe 250 dollars per year on to
maintain a single machine and an
experiment essentially takes a minute
and if you plug in all these numbers
what he come up is that one of these
machine in principle can run
half-a-million experiments a year this
of course means like day and night but
people can access it from all over the
world and an individual experiment this
is less than a cent right so it's really
something where you can think of for
example addressing 5 million students
and you guess that every year go to a
similar kind of grade level basically
really supplying certain biology
experiments at scale and at low costs
right and so that's something
we're now thinking of how to really
scale this up and and make this make
this happen and of course we also varied
or not worried I mean concerned about
generality right so far we always saw
this light from the side we can use
other stimuli as you saw from big from
before right like projecting from from
above we can also use different
organisms
what you see here for example these are
can you clean ourselves and what's
coming in here is Volvox it's a awesome
microorganism but actually a
multi-celled ball and if you shine light
on this actually moves to the light
while you glean a move away from the
light so interact the different organism
you also see if you follow closely how
these cells kind of generate a
hydrodynamic flow fields it's from other
cells around and so again lots of things
to be discovered and then to be seen and
one of the tricky thing is always if we
want to bring this thing stable online
is again a maintenance questions like
which types of organisms lend himself
well for being robust and don't need too
much logistics on our end in terms of
maintenance ok so finally I want to tell
you about an earlier cloud lab project
which is an interesting contrast because
it's working on a different length and
time scale and also is not as scalable
as the first one but on the other hand
maybe more have more utility for
students actually building setups like
those themselves and the system involves
basically petri dishes and excuse me an
organism called for Sorum that has a
chemotaxis response so focus on this one
so this is a petri dish about this size
in yellow you see the organism in red
it's indicated where robot basically
puts food particles the whole movie
lasts over a day so it's much slower
experiment and here an image is taking
it at about every 10 minutes and what
you can see is that this yellow organism
essentially follows this trail of food
right and you always see like a branch
is a little bit out but essentially
grows right here initially it grows
everywhere then finds the food and then
moves along the food trail and the
experiment essentially works like this
that the student logs in every couple of
hours program sister to robot for a few
more segments of the food trail and then
comes
a few hours later and see how the
organism has responded the system itself
we built out of Lego builder pipetting
robot and didn't have a flatbed scanner
below that basically takes images of
multiple of these dishes so here's the
interface where you can basically select
your experiment and you could route it
to a particular one you see your petri
dish and then you program essentially
this food trail by I mean just drawing a
line and then telling beforehand what's
the what's the time difference between
those and these are the robots did not
execute execute these experiments and
what's interesting now is that I mean we
have these robotics classes in school
and after-school programs that now
students could also build robots like
that and then get kind of disloyal
mechatronics education more also until
into the life sciences right so and then
after the robot has executed it the
image is placed in a database and you
can come back and see what you've done
so again this is the robot this is
basically the pipettor which is all made
out of Lego except a normal syringe so
it's pretty low cost and here on this
business basis standard server rack
where we have three such machines each
of them having six six of such dishes
they're just important for us kind of
just to try to understand the technology
if you have Marton machines in parallel
each with multiple experiments how do
you route and synchronize all of that so
don't actually what this this kind of
schematic is showing here so you have
multiple of these machines each of them
running multiple experiments on the
other hands you have to use on and this
setup is actually very different from
the real time you clean a lab that you
saw before because before video cleaner
it is like one user checks out an
experiment owns it for like a minute and
that's the experiment and then gets put
up again well here all these machines
operate autonomously the user only puts
input into a database and the machines
query what they need to do and then do
multiple things in parallel right so two
very different modes of operandi and
what's interesting and important is that
in the biotech space we get more and
more high throughput
equipment right for pharma and research
and so forth
you can now imagine how you use this
kind of high scroop would HIGHLY
paralyze the equipment to run
many experiments in parallel but rather
one scientist runs 10,000 experiments in
one run what about 10,000 students
running one experiment each and so I
used this this set up in a class at
Stanford a graduate level class that I
taught but the students essentially ran
experiments over over ten weeks and you
see some examples where student for
example test for the DOE organism
responds more to can distinguish between
lots of food roses little food how
strong if a kink it can follow things
like those and then a student would
analyze the data measure fractal
dimension grow speed and then also make
make some models and here's kind of
another example of a little bit more
simplified robot where you can for
example program in 24 well plates as you
see here a food color gradients right
something that is very easy to do is
this colorful you can now think about
more colorful mixes and we also can do
as more complicated experiments where
you use bacteria that you induce certain
gene expression that they lead to Kalos
right and so what this can really show
is students how I mean give a feel for
what in this industrial robots are
actually doing and how robots can
actually facilitate experiments right
take the labor of the person and enable
you to think more about programming and
and experimental design rather than
physical labor and and hands-on skill
and so kind of division where all of
this this leads to this kind of cloud
laughs I mean talked quite a bit about
education and you've heard about MOOCs
and things like those another project
that we now starting is working with
physicists with a kind of a small select
group of people that we allow give
access to our cloud labs and so they can
run experiments based on down choosing
but then really try to come up with
interesting research questions and then
make models around that other 'mo long
term vision is of course really using
high-throughput
equipment on these kind of machines and
this kind of infrastructure supposed to
research and also education we can also
think about citizen science for example
so what if here in case you don't know
for example folders when you turn our
projects where are tens of thousands of
people help kind of solve biological
relevant problems and so what if we kind
of are enable I mean regular people to
design their own experiments and thereby
contribute to the scientific and that
one so to kind of now step out a little
bit conceptually what I talked about is
interactive biologic biology right like
we want enable people to do experiments
in a very convenient way and what do we
need for that right we always need of
course on biology we need some sensor
and we need some actuator and if you
want to interface that with our standard
electronic world we'd like to have a
digital input and a digital output but I
mean you can think about interactive
biology where you don't have that but as
you saw for example if you want to build
cloud labs or whatever we eventually
need to kind of interface with these
kind of digital infrastructures that we
are so heavily used to right and so if
you are kind of connect something to the
stage around then you can make a close
relationship or comparison to other
chips that we know kind of CPUs GPUs and
so forth right where you can say you
have an input and then something
magically happens and some output right
some digital output and the same thing
happens here except there's some
biological process in the middle that is
noisy has some other properties right
and so for that reason we kind of call
this sort of setup ionic processing unit
or ppyou and we can also ask like what
what's a performance metric of such a
BPU of any solar system right like you
know how how fast is your CPU clocked
all these kind of things how many
operations can it do what would that
mean for system like that and you could
for example say if you look back at this
earlier system where after this
projector in this camera you could say
let's let's assume we have a certain
project on the camera HD there's a
certain amount of information process
through they are and use test as a
measure but that's not a good one
because if you have no biology in
between then all you get is some
meaningless stuff out of it right so
that that can't be the answer can't be
good measure so we need to take those
into account and the way we now think
about it is really asking the question
if you as a user provide a stimulus how
much of a response to you see if you
provide a stimulus and don't see any
response essentially watching a movie
right so really what's what's the
feedback that you get and the way to
capture this is actually a mutual
information right so from information a
theoretical perspective basically from
the response that you see how much can
you learn about your stimulus and the
more there is presumably the more you
can interact or the more people can
interact at the same time just to make
this a little bit more concrete so if
you're for example just have two LEDs
and it takes about 10 seconds for cell
to show visible response right then you
can say one bit every 10 seconds like
within 10 seconds you can say which
which of the two lights has been on if
you have four LEDs then you already have
two bits if you now think of this
projector system where we can show from
a things from above have multiple cells
in certain sub areas you can actually
get to higher levels on the other
extreme if you think back about this
forum system where we took only an image
of attend every 10 minutes and the
typical growth rate and that kind of
length scale is in the order of 20
minutes you actually get to much much
lower bitrate right and if you know if
you know ask yourself if you wanna for
example surf a certain number of
children to do biology experiments or
maybe research shows to do certain
experiments and want to ask which system
should you build right you could use
these kind of quantitative measures of
saying like here's the kind of power of
investigation that you have right
okay so to find the flight I want to
want to talk about so when you first had
our our games out there some people
asked like this is actually ethical to
play with living organisms why and I
don't know whether the audience wants to
respond to that and anything away do the
Paramecium know other
so these self-serving II don't know
because then yeah because they're not
sentient right but but it prompted us is
going to bioethicists at Stanford and
really unwrapping this and this issue
and basically coming up with the number
of possible objections one could have um
so there's of course the question of
animal welfare right like mean do we
hope something to be cause pain there's
kind of a general question respect for
life right if you play with these
organisms this is something like you're
disrespectful to single-celled organism
whatever that means actually lots of
these things we also cut from online
responses so we are some YouTube videos
where people are commenting and they're
going through these actually those are
some of the comments we find from they
are can can kind of characterizing so
some people are saying like this is
playing God that's that's not really
should do some people say this looks
yucky right like something may say this
is slippery slope right may be fine to
do it the single-celled organisms but
later you do it with mice and that may
not be okay
right so don't even go there some people
may say it is a trivial pursuit right
like this is taxpayers money I mean
should we spend money on this couldn't
you do something more useful with your
time question about public safety right
like it's doing this gameplay suddenly
killer virus generated that gets
released into public there's also things
about game ethics right like I mean do
we generate games that did are good
games that are in joyful for therefore
the play are not frustrate kind of fine
the other questions which are kind of
more longer fetched but if you think
about scientific discovery games if
things are discovered and who owns the
discovery things like that right so this
well some kind of some of the major
themes many of them have the
relationship in kind of many other
bioethical debates right and so what we
then sit down and said like let's make a
few recommendations kind of setting some
boundaries of what we want to do here to
kind of really here on the safe side so
an obvious one is don't cause any pain
or harm so basically the non-sentient
organisms i always want to point out
that these cells that you have they are
single-celled organisms and when you put
your pizza in your oven you kill lots of
yeast right which are kind of a similar
complexity and you don't even think
about that
right we should totally engage with the
public and saying why are we doing this
that's why also give talks here right
and saying I mean we have a mission to
kind of engage people and teach find new
ways of teaching about biology and
biotechnology especially since it is an
area that increasingly more in
influences our lives right we should
show respect for life it's always a good
question what does this exactly mean but
if you think about playing that your dog
right I mean you can throw a steak and
the dog brings the stick back and you
have kind of a positive relationship or
you could make a game where two dogs are
fighting which is something which we
don't like right and to really think of
how to incorporate that and you should
also have respect for the player so
really make games that in the end you
think there's some positive outcome for
for that for that person right so those
are kind of some recommendations and
publish an ethics paper on that and so I
started my my talk with some
relationships between computer science
and biotechnology and here's a graph so
which kind of makes the point this some
sort of a 50-year gap if you want to say
so between the two right there was kind
of the early foundations of computer
science like quantum mechanics can be
may be matched up this discovery of DNA
structure there's what we call the
golden years and then eventually there
was the transistor and the first
integrated circuits which we now also
have in biology right and you can
basically fit a line through it and say
50 years and you can of course also say
when did the first videogames come up
and what did we do here so we write on
the on the slope at what we are doing
okay so that ends my talk so the main
thing I want to highlight what we're
interested in is providing an
interactive experience between
macroscopic human and microscopic
organism we built now a number of these
systems learned a lot there's a lot to
be said about how do you make stable and
robust technology and then there are a
number of applications lots of the
applications right now focused on
education which i think is a rather
straightforward one because if you want
to bring a million simple experiments
sorry single experiments with million
students the experiment is very simple
that's easier to achieve that
bringing very complicated experiments to
ten specialized scientists right but he
said the types of technologies in the
end should kind of relate to each other
so that concludes my talk and thank you
for attention so certain ideas like
could you not only have people involved
in data analysis and problem solving but
maybe even in data collection and in
experimental design and so the Eterna
project which which was known as one
slide by Richard Oz at Stanford is
already doing this to a significant
extent where are people basically design
RNA structures and they submit a design
and then these designs are synthesized
and then tested a further default
properly and they're really getting
people more and more involved in that
part of the of the research as well
another example would be would you see a
lot that people with a cell phones for
example goes to the wild and take images
of birds and other things right and
basically help with the data collection
so that you can nobody respond most to
blue and so first of all I mean UB is
the blue lightest more energy intensive
right but it's also a little bit
cheating because if you really cranked
up the red light extremely high and this
I mean these projectors also have kind
of some sort of a spectrum right
they were also avoid that so what really
chose to do something that gives a very
clear distinction studi user where the
blue gives a very strong response and
the other ones do not again it's a
little bit samey cheating because you
should not mislead the use of saying
like they don't respond to red light at
all
what do you mean affect them so City so
I mean if you have very strong light for
a long time right like when you make it
UV damage for example to the cell right
may heat up really depends on and what
exactly is going on yeah so um so you
saw the the chemical stimulus with the
robot right in the very first game that
I showed where we had like this
electrical stimulus right so we tried to
do more more organism more stimuli but
the thing is that the light is a it's
very easy to handle stimulus right
because very easy to switch on and off
and the other thing is that these cells
you cleaner cells are now very easy to
handle and so we would really like to
branch out but the more complicated
stimuli in organism is the more
complicated the technology gets any more
questions thanks again